alcohol if I if I if I if I open that
bottle I could I can stay up and then I
i love that if you go out and you have a
great meal with friends and then you go
home with a few friends and you have a
late night disco I mean you're not
dancing on the table but you you open up
a few bottles of wine you've great
friends and you playing music and talk
and rubbish that's a great thing in a
weekend you know so that keeps me up
late I i I'd tend to in the last couple
of years because I used to live right in
the city center I've moved out sort of
not the city centre county dublin near
the coast so i tend to get up early now
i am known to get up at seven in the
morning I like swimming you can have a
bad back I no choice there and i right
and as sometimes i go to bed at eleven
and then sometimes i go to bed at five
in the morning that's when i go out so
I'm but worried yeah I can I get anxious
I worry doesn't really do any good if
something's broken are in trouble you've
got to bend and pick it up and fix it
and worry just makes us get wrinkles so
try not worrying